boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
today we're seeing down to anumita Guha
hello hello thank you for joining thank
you for having me
I'm really excited thank you so much
again yes yes always on the other hand
oh I should show you the what I learned
from the connect from the connected guys
also they're working on human
connectivity in place so you put your
hand out like this
Ellis camp match and then you just do
this and then you just you look at the
other person's eyes okay and then you
just feel and then you go you know this
works
why it's two things so when their hands
are touching and if it's after like 9 or
10 seconds our bodies release oxytocin
and then eye contact makes that better
yeah and then the vibrational sound
depends on like a chakra yeah so
different if you believe in that right
the different chakras have different
forces there's one that that's for
connection that's a mmm sound that's
that's that's that's right oxytocin
trust both eyes and touch and then the
vibration that you're sending through
your body through the humming yeah yeah
the guys I love these two from Connect
they're they're really trying to bring
human connection to more people are in
the world I wonder if I would have been
more powerful if it was two hands they
sometimes do this one that's good and
then sometimes do this one in circles
okay I'll do this and then they'll do it
in a circle I'm just very in love with
touch and hug and yeah human connection
in general so important yeah okay let's
but you saw the title we're talking
about IBM Watson anumita Guha is a
product to manager at IBM Watson just
working on the developer labs team
across a our VR across just getting
these tools out to more people chatbots
going to talk about that today
I'm really excited here we go let's do
this let's do a new cognitive science
from Berkeley as well yeah exactly so
some linguistics in there like really
passionate about communication so we are
- so let's let's let's do this so tell
us a little bit about this background
you know where were you born what led
you to Berkeley yeah so I was born in
India actually move it around a lot one
of my like bingo fun facts that I share
with people is that my first five
birthdays were in five different places
and I think because of that I like
learned a lot about different people and
just different environments like I lived
in different parts of India I lived in
Kansas I lived in California so it's
just a very broad spectrum the one thing
that was constant in my life was just
people I I've always been a person that
got energy from being around people and
I know that to my parents who were very
very social creatures like growing up I
remember going to like three parties at
night and they're not like like they
just had a lot of different social
circles so I just met people from
different walks of life and different
socio-economic classes different races
and it was just very immersed and
exposed to that from an early age so as
I got older I one felt really tied to
like the human experience and learning
about what motives other people so that
was one thing that drove me to cogsa
because I was very fascinated by the
human brain and kind of unlocking the
keys to why we do what we do the brain
is also one of the four frontiers of
science that's not solved so there's
there's I think the ocean space the
brain we all start like super small like
micro cork esque things we don't know
answers to them yet and the other thing
that I would say is I also grew up in
the Silicon Valley we talk about those
for a lot on the show yeah like you're
diverse background and culture - that's
a big indicator of knowing that
individuality collectivism across
borders all that good stuff yeah I mean
there's a lot to learn oh so much I
learned like you're saying yeah yeah I
also grew up in the Silicon Valley so I
had like new tech gadgets in the house
all the time
and formed a very interesting
relationship with technology from an
early age I started like coding not I'm
not a coder by trade but designing
websites and different things and I was
nine years old and just kind of ran with
that as like a side hobby a side hustle
when I was younger so Cox I was so very
good like coolants of the two things I
liked and that's what this is well how
people will give birth in to the world
they get five birthdays in five
different countries when they're first
growing up and it'll just like that all
of a sudden your perception is shifted
and to new dimensions new new breaths
and depths so that's a good foundation
and then going into having all these new
gadgets
okay so then Cox I lean fell in love
with linguistics I went into Berkeley
Cox is a in Ursula nari major at
Berkeley different schools have it done
in different ways but at Berkeley uni
you learn six different subjects
linguistics is one of them psychology
anthropology neuroscience engineering
and philosophy that's all right
yeah that is so good and since we were
in Berkeley which is like an engineering
Mecca
we were housed under electrical
engineering so I learned a lot about
brain machine interfaces and different
things there but I wanted to I started
off with neuroscience and then I
realized I could kind of like the big
picture a little bit more science I love
and it explains the big picture but the
big picture is really where I'm I'm tied
to so like the two things I really liked
was the psychology and linguistics so
like how thought shapes or how language
shapes are thought and how like
different cultures have different words
for different things and how does that
actually change the way you perceive and
carry yourself in the world yeah
especially in Europe when you're just
taking a 1-hour train to a different
country and then they have a word for
something that you don't have a word for
in your culture and language then you're
like whoa
and I think in your example there were
like a bunch of different ways to say
the word blue
and that gives you a bunch of different
understandings of different shades in
India there's like a bunch of different
ways to say love yeah right and like
over a couple dozen ways and then I
guess here it's just only a couple
really ways of love and then I guess
lost and there's so other ones but their
affection but they're different they're
also different but the other thing I
find interesting is like gender roles
and gender pronouns in words so there's
a study that came out where like in
French and Japanese or German those
languages you attach a gender pronoun to
make it feminine yeah yeah so then when
you ask people to assign adjectives to
it then they're gonna attach more
feminine adjectives or masculine that
differently so like the basic example is
key so in one language I think it's
French and Jeff not Japanese they keep
saying that French and German one's
feminine one's masculine the feminine
noun that crew and you would describe
key they'd say like delicate gold
whereas when it was masculine let's say
like sharp functional yeah yeah that is
also very interesting that that kind of
nuance to language is so cool and it
seems to be you know Spanish is like
that I'm trying to think of
I think Russian has some like that but
I'm really fascinated by linguistics
George Zipp was actually the first
linguist that really inspired me
zips law because it follows a predator
distribution and then you're like yeah
one out of every six words we say is the
word the yeah and then you're like oh my
god and then just you know the first
only a couple of words in the English
language the most popular words like the
of and which two are like the half of
everything we say yeah and it's just
nuts to to follow the linguistics it's
like that and then it's applicable
across all languages so they do they do
so and this also really applies to
confid
it's encouraged because the more that
you say things like I can I'm empowered
to feel like I can make an impact and
that what I'm doing is important and
that people respect me and that they
they give me recognition that that whole
process is those that's that's the way
that your look that your language is
forming your thought and then other
people's languages form your thoughts so
it's also important and interconnected
when we communicate totally yeah and now
we're bringing that to technology
technology yeah okay so alright so then
how was this transition from we go to
from Berkeley to a couple of jobs prior
to Watts and what were you learning
along the way and how did you end up
getting into Watson yeah so I when I was
in college I actually wanted to go to
some sort of like clinical setting and I
actually ended up founding my own
company when I was in college it was my
first foray into tech on my own nice I
worked on it for like a full year and
ended up exiting from that and at that
point I was like I don't know if I want
to do that and I want to be indexed so I
just did a blanket search for cognitive
science and I got a job as a product
manager at a mobile app tech startup and
while I was working there my role was to
create new ad units for people around
the world that are playing games and it
was actually really fun for me because I
came from a background in research and I
was running about 30 or so eb tests a
day so i was researching at a very high
scale and very quickly and what was
awesome about my product was that it was
it transcended different parts of the
world different classes different
demographics everything so i was able to
pull out insights like people in china
respond to the color red because they
associate it with royalty whereas people
in the US is that's like a stop like
don't do that so understanding like it
was like a very like i supercharged my
brain with knowledge of human behavior
and I was able to do that and design
different audience and it was almost
like I call it dark UX or like designing
for behavior so if my goal is to get
them to click on an ad
how can I almost manipulate the end-user
to clicking on the ad and that's how we
made money and it was interesting
because you can like so Kamboj analytic
oh of you well I didn't stay there
forever
but yeah yeah but it can be used for
good as well if you're trying to
communicate a message of peace or
totally of other things then you can
figure out that Oh China cares more
about the color red face loyalty so
we're gonna make it add some red
everything goes back to connection how
do you connect with the other group of
people who are starting group of people
you want to connect with so I loved
working there it was really interesting
for me to just learn about everything
and everyone so quickly and then from
there I went to a couple of other
startups worked in analytical roles
creating products for analytics and
almost integration so I played a
partnership role we'll see how our
company's analytics could help other
people make smart decisions and I'm a
firm believer in like we live in this
like big data world it's not about big
data but it's about smart data so being
able to figure out which ones make sense
and how we understand diagrams and how
we want to see the information we want
to see so that's what I have been
working on and after a couple of years
there I realized I really want to go
back to more like traditional AI and
more of the roots of what I liked and I
had known about IBM and IBM Watson for a
very very long time like pre jeopardy
days because that's I studied research
papers and stuff from IBM research back
and when I was in school so I had a
friend at IBM Watson he was like hey
come join us and it was kind of like a
serendipitous joined this team and I'm
working to create developer tools for
developers building with Watson that's
awesome
it's been a little over a year right
yeah I'm glad you had a another example
of culture and
and linguistics and within technology
and its importance with even before
we're getting into chatbot yeah and that
interface and we're even still talking
about the way that a mat is designed
okay
so you had now you know you're starting
with the okay dude the developer tool so
IBM Watson's got a hundred or more of
these like developer tools that
companies can use that are either free
or paid yeah so the way I look at Watson
is that there's a bunch of it's like
most people think of Watson to be this
like supercomputer and it's more of a
technology that we have available for
everyone to use for AI and when we refer
to AI we think of it as not artificial
intelligence I mean it is artificial
intelligence but it's augmented
intelligence so we've created a
technology or an avenue for developers
and the world really to build an augment
the world that they're building and so
we have a bunch of micro services or API
is that different developers can use for
whatever they're trying to augment so
Watson assistant can be used to build a
chatbot or any form of conversational
interface and Alexis skill or a Google
home or an IOT device that was Watson
interfaces
you know what those subsection
interfaces of Watson know Watson
assistants Watson assistant yeah so
that's the technology you would use to
build it yeah okay so now there's one
branch called Watson a system okay and
that's for interfaces conversation call
for conversations applause this is for
conversations they're just technologies
that you would pull in so there's like
Watson visual recognition and that's
used to help recognize faces or read
text they recognize six different things
and we have a bunch of these services
that different people can use or they
will bring into a man this is really
great assistant
there's assistant there's visual
recognition there's Watson discovery and
that's used to you can feed it paper
like lots of papers and help drive
insights and you know like team words
themes maybe there's there's like an
empathy suite that we have which is
really cool where
you can analyze other people's tone when
if it's voice recording and or you can
read text and determine if they're angry
so emotion detection you can use that in
conjunction with assistant so a really
good use case for that is customer
service bots so if someone's calling in
or typing in you can cater the decision
tree or what the chat bots will say
based on how that person is feeling yeah
what else is there that's a really good
example yeah yeah and I can keep going
there's like 11 of them there's some 11
of them there's 11 maybe 14 it changes I
don't know where we are right now but
there's a handful of them we're growing
and the most popular one is assistant
yeah and then visual readiness is your
recognition and assistant I don't know
if it's I guess it depends on what you
define as popular most popular like most
reviews yeah yeah okay Isis it is and
should do Google and Amazon and Apple
use assistant so they have their own
like in company technologies at their
building what you'll notice like for
Alexa or for like Google home for
example if we're just talking about the
house home assistant space you will
build something on their platform and
you can only release it to their device
whereas with IBM when you build
something on Watson we're platform
agnostic so you can use their technology
and then you add it to different tech
like applications interfaces so it could
go in a Google home or it could go on an
Amazon Alexa and like we've created
partnerships with these companies to you
know bring AI to them so a couple weeks
ago we announced a big partnership with
Apple to use core ml and Watson vision
recognition to help recognize images I
guess offline and that is something that
we're Fassett like helping the iOS
developers use and they're they're now
able to like code and Swift and also
incorporate Watson to it
mm-hmm and that's for recognizing photos
when you're not connected to the
internet so as in the native Photos app
we'll start recognizing the phone yeah
or if you're a developer that wants to
build something then you don't need an
internet connection to do it so if
you're traveling maybe anyone I like use
like translation of of text you can do
it offline
snaps later yeah things you don't need
an internet connection for okay so most
let's let's keep going with this because
this is the this is really so much done
pack developer labs all right so we're
does AR and VR fit into the developer
tools
what's that most used for yeah so
developers have they come in different
flavors right like you could be an iOS
developer or a mobile developer an
Android developer web developer and then
there's now a concept of a our VR
developers developers that are creating
these virtual reality augmented reality
mixed reality experiences so whatever
platform they're using to build on
you can add AI to that and you would
want to bring Watson into that as an
option so it is a new nascent developer
market I would say and as the the
developer labs were always keen to
identify these markets that are growing
and what technologies are going to be
more pervasive in our world moving
forward so we want to be able to empower
these developers and have a eye on them
so this is like leveraging Watson with
unity mm-hmm yeah so the unity example
is how like you can use Watson assistant
speech to text text to speech and then
if you want to do sweet other things you
can but you can have voice commands or
speech interactions in a virtual reality
interface so we have last year we
announced a partnership with Ubisoft
which is a VR game that you you're in
Star Trek you're in the command center
and you can have
commands issued so you don't actually
have to press buttons but it's a very
interactive game now we can be like warp
speed Red Alert different things and
your it uses Watson to recognize that
and also make like take actions right
there
so it's voice to text and then the text
is processed and then made decisions
yeah okay so how many ARV our labs are
now using Watson tools I don't have a
number for that I wouldn't say ARV our
labs but I'm sure there are a lot of
independent developers yeah that are
building with Watson if you go to the
unity asset store as a unity VR VR
developer you'll be able to download the
Watson SDK and then they can add voice
commands and different things on to
their system okay and then then the
developer tools are also trying to be
used for things like blockchain and open
sourcing yeah I work in a completely
open sourced environment we want to I'm
a firm believer and like when one one of
us succeeds all of us will cuz we're
working in new technologies right so
we're all trying to move the needle in a
sense so by open source again we're able
to help others move the needle and my
team works on different Watson services
and developer tools for them my larger
organization focuses on blockchain or
IOT more emerging technologies cloud and
container services how we can you know
bring those together and bring
developers onto our IBM platform so the
blockchain and open source involvement
is because you're trying to bring the
developer tools to those communities
right yeah so but it's also happening
internally so what you're saying you're
also it's happening internally Anna
yeah yeah so for blockchain iBM has a
specific stance on blockchain and I am
NOT well-versed enough to actually
articulate that but
what we're building is we're releasing
this like hyper ledger fabric that
enterprises and developers can use to
build something on the blockchain and
the example we use there is like
tracking maybe like food tracking that
goes from like if you think of a
fishmonger and it pick it up in Japan
who every single person in the chain
that touches it until it comes to your
plate so those sort of inner uses cases
rather than like a private network that
like Bitcoin is built on so there's what
blockchain can be done you know it like
what can be done with lock chain is
undetermined right now there's so many
things that can be done and there's an
entire team at IBM that's working on
that okay and then you're one of your
roles is to get the developer tools out
to more people working as well in the
blockchain space as well yeah so my I
don't focus on blockchain my peer is
creating tools for developers that are
building an exact chain I'm more so
creating tools for developers that are
building your arv are conversational
interfaces chat BOTS voice bot yeah like
visual recognition like Watson services
and then there's also another part of
this as for IOT as well so there's
another whole part of Watson that's
being developer tools are being built
out for IOT and then also for people
that are onboarding to the IBM cloud and
using different container services like
kubernetes and docker what is that again
so it's a way to make your system run
faster and organize like your back-end
system so when you have things on the
cloud you can containerize them yeah and
have like you know like little mini
computers almost yeah yeah that sounds
way more efficient than having it all
just trying to process without these
huge use cube kubrick uber Neddie mm-hmm
yeah that's never been called cube con
cube con is that named after someone or
I actually have no idea who queue
brunetti kubernetes it's containerized
the data that's in the cloud and that's
how to optimize it yeah okay
yeah exactly okay so all right let's do
another visual oh so okay so we have IBM
Watson and then we have the developer
tools that go down so there's a team
working on the IOT developer tools the
team working on the blockchain developer
tools which you don't dude but that is
what's happening and then there's a team
working on the ARV are tools which you
do work with that and then there's a
team that's working on the chat
interface or the human interfaces
assistant interface that stuff and then
you also work on those development
requests okay so now we know let's say
are those two for kind of like the IOT
the blockchain the AR VR and then the
interfaces with are those I say I think
three there's emerging tech and that
includes blockchain IOT okay there's
cloud containers and that includes
containerize in cloud all of that then
there's Watson okay and then underneath
Watson would be like ARV are
conversational interfaces any of the
Watson services no sit at the beginning
Act okay so we did kick cloud was over
here emerging tact emerging tech cloud
and then Watson Watson cloud emergency I
think of Watson if you want to be more
broad to be AI and analytics okay yeah
AI and analytics yeah yeah cuz you're
also providing insights into the data
well we have a lot of Watson services
that allow you to get inside so there's
different and then you can also attach
analytics to other services so an
example is there's an AR tool that's
built and it's open source anyone can
use it where you can manipulate data in
AR with your voice so you put on maybe a
microsoft hololens and then you can see
all things like data scatter plots you
can say like show me all of the data
from this date to this date of people in
San Francisco and then it'll change it I
know meta so cool
yeah they're so cool I've been loving
watching and retweeting their videos I'm
all about that life I'm so ready to just
freaking aware that and
and just experience because hololens is
good i mean another another discussion
that's so interesting i'm so excited
about democratizing like education and
and getting all these unique insights in
the 3d world in this 2d like inner
screen data I think is a great example
because you literally have another
dimension right instead of looking at a
2d bar graph you can see other things
and drive different insights that you
would physically not be able to before
yeah your brain doesn't work that way
and there's so much of it like you said
it's not just about the amount of data
but the quality also like what what's
them how are you running on machine
learning on the data sets - yeah our CEO
Ginni always says 80% of the world's
data is actually privately owned so
there's so much data out there that
different corporations and companies are
owning yeah and they can do so much with
that right yeah I'm ready for the
decentralized AI economy that's what Dan
Daly was on our show talking about that
these horizontal marketplaces of data
where Amazon's opening up with IBM's
opening up with Google's opening up with
Apple and they're all just working
together yeah in Facebook and that's
because the companies that don't open up
will get left behind so I'm really
interested by that well catch up they're
like oh we have our data now and then
forward yeah yeah and the insights will
be so much more useful and profound for
us yeah after the data sets are open
rather than the closed one yeah and like
if you think of the applications for
like human good right like if there's a
natural disaster how can we get the
right need you have to you as quick as
soon as possible right so being able to
bring in all the different forces from
the government from what you use what
you need right we can make those
connections faster and get it - yeah
yeah you shoot me my damn product that I
want within 10 seconds now now I want it
within 10 seconds it's getting
ridiculous
and the supply and how we're doing it
okay I like I like the emerging tech the
cloud and then IBM Watson AI and
analytics so alright now let's go back
to unpacking the AI any analytic side of
things because this is kind of where
your sweet spots are so okay so now
under the assistant we have the
conversations that you know whatever
with google assistants having Siri
Amazon Alexa
then what argued like the main IBM one
whereas IBM providing this emotional so
so so much when I was saying like before
right like the google has something
Amazon has something apple has their
home pod Siri we're not we're not
creating a device if someone is in IBM
I'm not aware of it but what we are
doing is creating the ability for you to
add intelligence to that so like in
layman's developer or startup can use
our technology to build their own
assistant build their own chat BOTS
build their own voice bot or we have
this cute little robot that we use when
we teach students and like I'm involved
like girls who codes like you know how
do we get them interested in tact so we
have a little robot that we create out
of card road called TJ bot named after
ibm's founder Thomas J Watson and you
can talk to it and you can also have
like lights or different like motors
like move the hand to indicate different
things yeah
and that's something you talk to yeah we
kind of smart mirrors for our TV is
whatever it may be and then conversation
AR VR so all of that falls under
conversational interfaces and Watson
assistant so that's like the core
technology that you'll use and then
everything else becomes it like a signal
service to it yeah yeah yeah okay so so
TJ bought I think I remember someone I
remember attending a meet-up where I
learned from a developer that was
evangelizing IBM's tools like two years
ago he brought a little TJ shot and it
was super fun to watch him
doing the evangelizing it was super fun
so okay so this so you were mentioning
okay so see we take all these different
so I'm gonna get to girl C code and stem
I want to get there as well that's
really cool so you take TJ bot and or
anything that I'm building into the
world and if I want to add some sort of
intelligence to it is that tool free for
me to use so T's so okay so you have the
TJ pot you want to use something called
a Raspberry Pi do you know what that is
it's like a small little like look think
of it as a computer is like a very small
little computer that attaches on to that
and it you have to buy that if you get
like a TJ bucket they all come together
but you can take the Raspberry Pi and
attach it to anything so like displays
your microphone whatever you want and
then to use the Watson services it comes
in different tiers is that is it
basically a motherboard with with a like
it is very small Intel chip or something
yeah yeah I don't know the details
exactly okay and then you can connect it
to lights you can connect it to you know
we can even hardwire it to your computer
you can connect it to a motor to move
like the TJ BOTS arm okay then so to
actually connect it to the Watson
services it comes in different tiers so
our first here which is our simplest
tiers II is free so anyone can build on
it and get started and then from there
depending on your usage that's when
we'll engage conversations of how we're
gonna pay for it so large enterprises
that have huge volumes yeah it's gonna
be different than you know us getting
started
yeah or you know it allows you to kind
of like try and buy sweet and then based
on volume so for example let's say that
let's use the mirror one that's fun okay
so there's a there's an Raspberry Pi on
my mirror and let's say that it what
would be a good use case for it I don't
know maybe you put a the camera on it as
well and then it does things like so
analyze how your
maybe you didn't get enough of sleep or
maybe you look over like you've gained a
couple pounds or or that that shirt
doesn't match those shoes yeah okay you
can also use a mirror to give you
information so there's hospitals testing
this right now where the mirrors in the
hospital rooms are actually intelligent
mirrors we can go there and be like
patient's vitals you'd like announced
that yeah and then I'll show that onto
the mat yeah exactly so like your
calendar for the day or your incoming
this is going for us that might make
more sense I would love to have a mirror
that I'm looking at in the morning
getting ready and be like okay call my
my lyft or uber now right or like what
time do I need to be here or anumita is
sexy
maybe yeah like a mirror on the wall
time yeah yeah yeah there's always need
for affirmations in the world right yeah
yeah you look in hella good today girl
I'm like thank you I do it I do it
mirrors how's my hair yeah yeah yeah
okay can maybe camera and take a selfie
for me I don't even need to do it mm-hmm
okay so soon then the amount of data
that it's then using Watson for maybe
like ten requests a day or something
what so it depends by service so for
Watson assistant it's per API call so
every time you send a signal and when
you're chatting for virtual or sorry
visual recognition its images recognize
fur and it's like ten are free or like
ten per day are free or it depends like
okay it depends on usage and it it's I
think definitely more than ten and then
after that it's at the charge of like a
very small amount for like every every
call it's like point zero one Center so
okay okay but got it
I don't have the pricing memorized so
you go to our website to get it there so
after like maybe a thousand calls it's a
dollar or so yeah that's pretty cheap
isn't it yeah but if you think of
thousand calls right like if this
conversation was completely chat right
like our hi hello this would have been
definitely a couple thousand yeah
right yeah yeah that's it's our three
guys right now our three goals yeah it's
true because it and now I guess this
might be a good time to go into let let
let's go into that okay so you've been
you had the linguistics background and
then we have the chatbox okay so and
this is the chat for good is also part
of the one of your also givebacks yeah
young girls as well so we'll get to that
and and girls who code as well as I want
to talk to about FIRST Robotics as well
but that's towards end as we go down
here we're going as we go to chat BOTS
and we leverage your linguist background
and now we have your AI in your computer
background what is going on right now in
the space we were just talking about
these yeah yeah yes those this is you
know I wrote down that I really wanted
to talk to you about the eyes yeah
because I don't even need to say words
well so there's two types of
communication all right there's a bone
you can just and then there's nonverbal
yeah right and eyes as part of nonverbal
and the stat I think is 93% of
communication and the number of changes
but between like the 92 to 96 range of
communication is nonverbal yeah hand
movements how their body language rate
so when you are texting much right
exactly yeah so when you're texting
versus talking on the phone versus in
person like if you just think of how
your interactions are you get a lot more
about the world when it's face-to-face
in person versus texting Oh or even
phone call yeah when you get inflection
and yeah yeah so when you're creating a
bot is such a bad and medium yeah I mean
it's just such a bad medium it's good
but it's also so bad you know how many
miscommunications a curve man text all
the time and people like read into them
the wrong way and I didn't actually mean
that and then it's evolving new
like languages like emoji you talk and
then we're limited by the bandwidth of
our meat sticks pressing they're like
versus the voice and the voice text oh I
always voice text it's so much faster
I love voice text and then the one time
where you say like a paragraph and you
look at your phone and nothing typed
you're like damn good connection yeah
okay so now I button over 90% isn't yeah
so I always highlight this when I'm
working with anyone that's doing
conversational design and early phases
have their bot development because if
you're creating a chat bot it's very
different than when you're creating a
voice pot so if you're creating an Alexa
skill yeah you the way we talk is very
different from the way we type and then
if you're creating a conversational
entity in air VR you get you know this
dimension you can you get hand movements
you get all of that so you can you
change your conversation so you have to
be aware via text you probably wouldn't
get as you're maybe typing there's no
room for the chat bot to message
something while you're typing up the
message - it can even while you're
typing it but for example with when I'm
speaking to the chat bot then as I may
be telling it about my day yeah it can
say something like uh-huh you know or
whatever or that's so interesting or
whatever right you know in that way it's
actually seems like I'm just talking
yeah it's giving me a little reply as we
go so now I mean that that decision tree
is very fascinating to me to us when and
this is just maybe this is part of that
empathy suite but when do you figure out
how to how to plug in a little so I
think I think it comes down to the use
case of your bot right so why are you
creating this so earlier we talked about
customer service right so in customer
service use cases you don't want to be
talking to a bot or a human or anyone
for that long you just want your problem
resolved right but if it's a chat bot
that's being used to you know for habit
formation for humans or to teach you
something right or therapy therapy BOTS
are a big thing now you
want it to be more of a communication
you want to establish a trust and it's
very different then you know going in
getting your solution and leaving so
they didn't even relieved me a review I
did so well yeah so it's it's very like
it's very contact specific and it's very
like not just like what kind of bot
medium it is but it's what kind of
conversation it's going to be and then
even within it it's it's also like
environmental and contextual so if it's
a chat bot on Facebook versus SMS versus
slack versus like like a web interface
people are interacting with them
differently because people have
different mental models for each thing
and then the same thing with like a car
that you talk to you're gonna be very
different than when you're at home with
your you know Google home realize that
so as you get started to build I
encourage everyone to be like okay let's
take 20 steps back and figure out like
who are you creating this for what
problem are you solving for them and why
do we care and then let's build it cuz
now that there's like a lot of people
that are like I need a bot and I need
this because it's the new cool thing to
do but maybe you don't need one mm-hmm
and I really enjoy your examples that
was a really good one Holy's trying to
like solve the problem solving for your
customer service stuff yeah that's
always like get in get out huh thank
goodness that that's done now that's off
my to-do list versus the the process of
built basically you know coming home to
the speaker that's on the table to you
the system that's on the table and and
and being able to request food or
request a conversation or request
information or request to learn from it
for a period of time about a subject
that you're interested in that that
becomes much more like oh crap that's
like a 15 minute intimate conversation
with an assistant versus yeah yeah a in
and out bots that are games right like
you're doing that for leisure and
entertainment hmm so like there's Alexa
skills where you can like name that
or do different things or box that will
like teach you different words every day
and that's something you're doing for
yourself and people take games for hours
how many bots are there that do things
like the word per day or the president
per day or the country fact per day or
the star since our day or whatever I
don't have stats on it because it's it's
in different you know ecosystem let's
get into that space
fine I love education tools like yes but
I will say like the entire like voice
community is growing like Fort X so like
last and I'm not gonna quote Amazon
numbers I'm gonna get them wrong but
like where we are last year to where we
are now is like exponentially greater
and it's growing and what are their what
what are the people that are being hired
for that people that know how to take
like the developer tools that sell
Watson makes but then also people that
know how to like the human interface
designed with robots and it's geez it
could be anyone it could be you and me
yes yeah like if we're creating like
remember when the whole like app economy
boomed right so when the iPhone came out
everyone's creating apps now everyone's
creating Alexa skills or Google actions
anyone can build it they have their own
developer that's what they're called
skills and actions
yes Alexa skills Google actions and then
when they're building it the developer
gets to make the choice of how I want to
build it so you can use like the skill
kit to build an Alexa scale and then if
you want to add AI to that you can bring
in Watson or you can bring in the other
like not frameworks damn skills and
actions yeah it's the first time hearing
about them that's so cool it won't be
the last time you know this is it's
probably the Forex Inc yeah yeah yeah
that's so much yeah we're for sure more
hopefully I keep having really great
conversations of people hopefully I can
introduce we can on the show introduce
more of what Watson's doing as well as
more of what is being done with these
with the the chat by interfaces
especially for educational purposes I'm
really excited about that yeah so I
actually chopped lots are very easy to
build tell us about that process yeah
like most chatbot development tools so
to get started you can it's an interface
you don't need a background in coding so
like one of the reasons why my
partnership with girls who code exists
is because we're building chat BOTS
we're teaching girls to build chat BOTS
specifically empathetic chat BOTS but if
you have no background you can get up
and running with a chat by in a couple
of hours and that's because there's all
these developer tools and different
interfaces that you can work with to get
you started and it's only getting you
know easier to build and then where the
actual technical juices come in is when
you're connecting it with different
services for example so on my team does
the piecing of it look you said no
coding background it just it's a visual
yeah it's like a WYSIWYG drag-and-drop
like I want to create this I want to
create this since it would be like
what's it really gonna give you an
example of an incoming message and then
your you'd give you maybe a decision
tree of like and then you could type in
what one option is one option is one one
option is and then it would be like okay
what about from there yeah just a lot of
tools out there that use a copy and
paste and ones to go back to the main
screen clone it you can like edit it you
can take the entire decision tree and
copy that and bring it to another
decision tree and build on that so cool
I need I'm gonna go mess with this yeah
you should yeah so I have yet what's the
URL for that for that so I would start
off with I would actually give you a
different recommendation at IBM we have
a hub for developers called IBM code and
when you go there you're able to get
pre-written code and like step-by-step
guides of how you can create your chat
so and there's also tools associated
with that so if you want to create your
own chat bot you can go into IBM code
and I would just Google like IBM code
BOTS and see what comes up yeah and then
you'll you'll find a bunch of github
links with read Me's that have a
step-by-step guide of what to do you can
click to deploy the code and it'll bring
you to the Watson assistant interface
that has this decision tree so you'll
already have the dialogues and
everything written and then you can move
things around in their Suites yeah and
then there's there's tools that I'm
working on my team is working on that
we're evolving to make this easier for
BOTS developers so something that I
launched earlier this various late last
year is called the bot asset exchange so
it is a marketplace for bot developers
aka Bay ok Back Bay is back I really
tried to get shirtless subway but yeah
you can go in and get this back end
conversation logic that different people
have created open source for you to use
so it's a community driven chat pod
development hub and you can if you want
to build a bot for you know to remind
you to set intentions for the day then
you can go there and see you if anyone's
already built that and you can grab that
code and then you can make it specific
to you if you want to build one that's
for pizza ordering you can do that the
bought asset exchange has right now over
hundred twenty back end conversation
logics that you can use stemming from
like IT enterprise use cases so like fun
ones like wine pairing and like what you
know restaurant you should go to and
it's it's growing so like you can go
download it or and once you create one
you can also upload it it's a
marketplace for bot conversations it's
so cool I'm in love I love that you're
in love I'm in such love with this ah
yes smart people thank you thank you
okay so so I just I can't I can't get
over all the different use cases and
where it's going and how how awesome it
is to time the young people into this
process okay so I guess we we did a
little bit of the ARV are where you
were you happy with where we were where
we like left with yeah okay okay all
right because I know there's so much
more to unpacking like all of these and
talk about each one of these it's like
its own conversation yeah and I mean we
could have we could keep going on all
the different use cases that are being
used for with the assistant right now
okay okay so tell us about the girls who
code you're all two girls who code er on
the coding for good yeah it's all so
that's awesome and then I wanted to
mention FIRST Robotics to you as well
because it's a an awesome organization
for youth to get involved in coding and
okay and building robots to complete
objectives on playing fields but also to
like practice teamwork and all those
skills is builds people builds really
good people like future leader people so
yeah so tell us about your involvement
in girls and stem yeah so there's so
many places they can get there so I
think people ask me like hey like the
people meeting parents will be like I
want my child to get involved how do I
get involved or there's girls in the
world who want to get involved and they
don't know where to start so
organizations like girls who code and
online resources that's available it's
very very important and for that's for a
couple of reasons one right now there's
no formal education for computer science
any of that to extracurriculars which is
usually where you would form these
interests are very catered to boys in a
way so to bring girls to like a coding
camp you I always tell people to find
like an all-girl environment so it's
inclusive so they can cultivate their
own interest and move forward I think
your environment and where you're in
makes a huge difference and like you
need to be surrounded by like-minded
people that uplift you and like I mean
there's there's a total crisis in this
in
and tack in a way and I as a product
manager I think about this a lot because
like we talked about not enough software
engineers and software engineering is a
very covertly genderized role like 18%
19% of software engineers are women
which is actually less than it was
almost 20 years ago and the reverse for
nursing yeah and other things there's
also a really interesting stat about
like women actually make up 70% of the
workforce but like less than 50 40 % of
it contribute to the GDP which is I
think really fascinating and for us to
bridge that gap is gonna take years and
a lot of money well so so every day more
and more women are involved in work and
men are apparently doing some other [ __ ]
that is not involved work yeah sometimes
I guess is sometimes in some cases and
then about the could the contribution to
GDP is still skewed in favor of men even
though there's women that are working
yeah so how do you take all the right
steps and it starts very early on like
people so many factors determine where
you end up in life and that's your zip
code but your gender toys II play with
as a child because it changes how you
think and perceive the world how many
times you dropped as a baby yeah yes and
I remember my first engineering class at
Berkeley I like solve this problem set
we had and took it to my GSI he was like
you looked at it and he was like yeah
you could do it this way if you're not
an engineer are you and I was like what
he's like yeah I would solve it very
differently and this is how I would do
it but I thought of it differently
earlier right and like yeah that's why
diversity is very important because my
brain was very different from the
traditional engineering Brannen it needs
like encourage different people and
different mindsets and include it to
solve the world's problems yes I totally
agree high-five to that that's such a
good point
diversity is crucial to solving the
world's problems diversity of thought
absolutely and that's why going back to
like girls who code and
you need to start them from an early age
and I'm a firm believer like you can't
be what you can't see and empowered
women and power women so you have to be
yeah you have to give back and you also
have to push yourself forward so these
people can little girls can be like I
want to be this person you know so
getting them started from an early age
and an inclusive environment doing cool
things that they're interested in
building solving problems that they want
to solve that's relevant to them it's
what's gonna get them interested at an
early age and then you know go to
college
feel the confidence they need and come
be contributing members of society and
contribute to the GDP we're looking at
it in that angle so the I mean we're
amazingly right on track for that I love
it I love it I love it it's been on
track for that it's been going on track
for that and there's grill see code
you're doing chatbots for good you want
to tell us about that as well
so chatbots for good is really a way to
keep for people to think of technology
as not something that's coming to take
over your job and not you know be scary
or something that you don't want to
interact with but rather it's showcasing
the power behind these technologies so
chatbots
a RvR I consider them to be like empathy
machines like you can literally be in
another person's shoes when you're in a
RvR but when you're in a chatbot you can
talk to a girl who is getting water in
Uganda and just like learn what their
experience is like and they're being
used to like in a lot of different use
cases for like fundraising for learning
about other parts of the world so it's
like having a conversation right but you
can do it from your home on your phone
on the go anywhere and it really makes
the world a little bit smaller and makes
her mind a little bit bigger
mm-hmm so like chatbots for good is like
how do you create empathetic chat BOTS
that are like one functional but also
have a higher
and encourage other people to think in a
different way and expand their mind yeah
I love I like the example that you gave
that it does contract the world but it
expands our minds I like that I like
being able to doesn't require another
person on the other end and it's it's a
it doesn't preclude other people from
using the chatbot either which is great
so a million people can be using at any
time it's a lot of API calls isn't worth
it yeah yeah of course it is of course
it is and that's where IBM makes that
Monday and that's where they pay you
from and I say why they pay you the big
bucks I get some bucks I get some bucks
okay and then yeah well and this is good
we have the first robotics as well
that's bringing also the STEM fields
exploding getting women involved young
girls involved is getting more and more
thanks to great initiatives that you're
a part of and that you're building and
okay let's walk you down some of our
simulation questions okay okay
all right I'm interested to hear what
you think about there seems to be a lot
of US and China and Russia the kind of
racing for AI for biotech or who's gonna
be superior in these fields how do you
think we should figure out how to work
together as we globalize yeah that's a
great question I was actually reading an
article in Bloomberg asking that same
question this morning hey hey we're on
the right track and they were doing me
like interesting charts of like like how
do you define the race right different
though there's not really a tangible way
to do that it could be the number of
patents in it it could be you know the
number of products or services that
launch out of it but I actually don't
think that's the right answer I think
the right answer is like how do we use
AI to solve most problems and that's how
we will determine you know who's winning
and I don't think it's a matter of like
country to country it's a matter of like
like technology again brings us together
right and how do we all work together to
solve these problems
it's what problems were solving what
problems we all care about and you know
like moving towards that I think is the
right answer so to identify the problem
on a global level and then try and pull
resources and to solve that problem
rather than make it like always made it
in this country and we're gonna charge
you two times as much yes yeah yeah yeah
I hear I hear you there and then there's
I totally feel you and want that and
then there's also like this crazy other
argument which is that that the United
States needs to be like the global
leader of the world and we need to make
sure that like communism or the
craziness of other nuclear war and other
bio warfare doesn't occur and the only
way to ensure that is by us being the
leader and then so there's a fascinating
like mental globalization conversations
that are occurring and I always like to
ask our guests about that
I'm glad you literally read about it
this morning that's so cool I totally
agree
even though it might be based on some
based on a little bit on patents and
like the amount of people using it a
little bit it's totally unlike have you
solved a problem leveraging AI or
leveraging biotech oh you have oh [ __ ]
like already like for example we just
had just I'm Josh Tetrick from just on
the show and just as a biotech company
that makes eggs without eggs they make
you know out of mung beans and and stuff
like that and so you know their products
are in a hundred and fifty thousand
stores so you know that's a pretty good
distribution point so if you think about
it that way then I think that impact in
the fields of biotech is super awesome
yeah
it may be compared to you know somebody
having a patent on some process that
isn't even applying any yes life yet
here's the other thing that I think is a
little tricky we don't really have a
definition for AI yet like when we refer
to AI and most people traditionally
think of it as machine learning or like
data mining but like what is AI and I
think our definition of that is still
evolving which is why we're not even
ready to
answer that question because what we
think of AI and the US might be
different from what people think of it
in totally and that comes back to the
linguistics yeah yeah
yes yes okay so how about what do you
think we should do about wealth
concentration it's like eight people
have as much wealth as the bottom four
billion what do we do about this massive
wealth inequality jab yeah yeah that's
an interesting question I've actually
like I thought of this a lot growing up
too because when I visit India it's
really interesting to see the
stratification between the rich and poor
there it's worse than here like the rich
people have everything and the poor
people have nothing and are taking like
what they have is being taken away all
the time that is that really yeah I'm
from Calcutta yeah no it's a big city
yeah that's how East yeah it's in West
Bengal the state yeah it was just a
weird cognitive dissonance thing I don't
know if there's a right answer to that
right like like what do I think of it I
I don't know if that's like should there
be a gap in general like should it be
one to one always and everyone has
equality I don't know
should the eight to one that you
described be like a four to one I don't
know I think I think so many things are
like tentacle to each other from this
system that we would really need to
understand like holistically everything
that would change and the ramifications
of that if we were able to bridge the
gap and I think what we should start
doing is going a little bit at a time
maybe to get to equality and see what
happens I think they're like there's
good and bad in every system right like
there's good things in capitalism
there's bad things in capitalism
same thing with like communism right so
like and it's also very subjective so
again tough question I don't think
there's a right answer
but society trying to solve that problem
on a global level is something don't
think it's a problem but some people do
I think like if you go back like
Maslow's hierarchy of needs yeah
everyone should have the basics right so
every single person should have food
shelter all that and I personally
believe in them and then as you continue
to grow up those levels I think that's
why shouldn't every person have
self-actualization and self
transcendence I don't know I think every
person could I don't even think everyone
has the ability to get their rights not
you don't think everyone has the ability
to get there yeah cuz I think you look
you'll hit a mental block at some point
right unless you open your mind even
more yeah I knew if you get there yeah I
think you have to work towards it yeah
you do but so we do have the ability
yeah it's just not give given to on a
plate and then I have to eat it yeah
yeah it's gonna be a lot of plates yeah
you have to break along the way like
have you ever seen that that in the gym
no it's like a guy that juggles plates
and there's a staircase going up to a
stage okay and then he's juggling the
plates on the stage and there's a
massive audience of a thousand people
watching him juggle plates but on the
stairs leading up to it they're a bunch
of broken plates yeah it's broken the
plates all the time leading up to when
he's on stage that's the same thing with
anything that you do I still fall on my
face all the time that's an interlocutor
conversation is and I am totally open to
it because that's how you become mastery
that's how you actually get there yeah
same thing with developer tools and and
chat boxes yeah everything you guys are
building I'm also like I'm a big
believer in the butterfly effect like I
think I think one thing will affect
everything else
I also believer that we're constantly
evolving like you and I are more evolved
individuals now than we were coming into
this conversation and that's my language
of all right yeah like we we exchange
ideas and we talk and we communicate
because it makes us better and like if
we go back to like Darwinian evolution
or survival is going to be better
because we have more information and if
you go back to terms like we're not on
speaking terms it's because you don't
like this person and you don't want them
to evolve because it's sharing them from
oh damn that is intense what do you
think Ron how do you like those apples
no you can't dance with everybody and
sometimes you know you help people they
may take you down down the road so you
have to be careful kind of live like
natural selection type dealio yeah it's
like if you don't like someone you just
yeah you don't talk to them and then you
don't want them to evolve anymore that's
that's kind of crazy you can't help them
sometimes you can't yeah exactly
sometimes you just can't help and you
don't want them do you you want them to
evolve so you can come with us let's go
we're gonna have a good time we're gonna
hit a couple yeah just like I don't want
to bring I don't want to bring any salad
or any goodies to the picnic and you're
like no but you have to like here are
ways to make salad and then they're like
don't listen that's it then will you go
on a picnic with them later
well yeah if correct yeah that's that's
the conversations that happen around the
world and I do believe in the butterfly
effect as well but yeah exactly even
something like a digital zeros and ones
being sent somewhere because you wanted
a message someone about something that
can cascade so much more down yeah chain
okay how about what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world
most beautiful thing in the world
I find a lot of beauty and like solace
and feeling small yeah so like we live
the world is really big
I like the everywhere the world is
really big and then the universe is big
and there's galaxies and we actually
don't know so like being able to pause
and reflect on that and realize that
you're you know like so small and
everything I think it's very beautiful
and something so small can have such
massive impacts on other people create
art you know have different like the
ideas of thoughts like everything is a
social contract and I think like just
stopping to think about how big and
small
you know what that dichotomy I think is
beautiful something so small can create
something so big I'm really happy you
said that yeah yeah I've been working on
shattering the ego for a long time yeah
whether it's through meditation or
through psychedelics yeah or there's so
many different ways to do the practice
but once you've done it or even looking
at the stars alright once you do this
practice over and over and over again it
just expands your mind in ways that you
can't go back to being so angle
eccentric yeah and and then even when
you do have to be egocentric like right
and like even right now we're being kind
of egocentric because we're talking on
the show but we're doing it playfully
like we're dancing through conversation
and that kind of thing versus needing to
be all like the that actual word that
you said didn't to make sense in that
sentence because of yeah that kind of a
thing so and I think like a hundred
percent agree with you and then when you
can step back and just like be happy and
I think there's different states of
happy there's like joy bliss happiness
right like what is it that you actually
want and like identifying that for
yourself and just truly just being happy
I think is beautiful
you know and that's you got to get those
passes mental barriers that are
preventing you from actualization of
transcendence like you were mentioning
earlier okay
how about do you think there's some
meaning or purpose to life yeah I think
so what is it I think the meaning and
purpose of life is to find your meaning
your purpose to life I think it's
individualized I think every single
person has their own life purpose or you
call it whatever you want there's I
think this goes back to the butterfly
effect and all of us are like that
everyone plays a role and they have
something to contribute and I like I
think one of my flaws but also one of my
strengths is I'm very trusting it's
whenever I meet someone I'm like you're
a great person and I accept them into my
life and that's also true with
technologies right like new technologies
come out like I'm gonna try this out and
I trust everything so I do think that
like just like in the spirit of being
trustful is that a word trustful
trusting truthful yeah yeah full of
trust is that everyone has a reason that
they're one walking into my life or we
were you know put together in this
situation and there's meaning to it mmm
it's good to to say that because then it
gives you more like I'm more driven like
it gives you power right versus just
being like oh I'm so pointless yeah
doesn't feel like it gives me power
right so I want to say the thing that
gives me power
even though philosophically it might be
you know there is no meaning what do you
mean me power
when you do say that what is happening
is happening for your own transcendence
and for other people's transcendence and
just this powerful collective and
individualistic force that just that
gives me energy to just function and be
and bring myself to the world and versus
if you know if we were just saying that
it's all meaningless that was that was a
meaningless whatever yeah and then that
it's like that doesn't give me any power
yeah I also think like as humans we all
need something to believe in
right so if you don't have that bullet
that's why like religion Texas and other
things exist I think it's because you
need something whether it be a
philosophy or something I'm like yeah
for me what I believe in is is other
people and you know their purpose and my
purpose and the meaning of life in a way
do you what is something that you
believe to be true that nobody else will
use to be true I feel like I shared most
of them already I think that the fact
that we're constantly evolving is
something that a lot of people will
disagree with I like cuz most people
would say like it's discrete moments or
something like that and I think it's a
minute-by-minute thing second by second
thing I also I don't believe in
mind-body dualism and I don't think
everyone believes them that looks for
like if your brain my brain swapped
who's alumns who's an amoeba
so if your brain Allen swaps with my
brain anumita which one of us is Allen
which one of us is anumita
so I am a firm believer in the mind and
the body being separate things but the
nervous systems also concentrated in
places yeah that's where yes and that's
where like it's a big debate cuz like
the brain and the mind I also think are
different things I like that question
though that's a good question yeah so
what's your answer that question so I
would argue that you'd be Allen I'd be
wherever my brain or my mind is yeah
that's an amoeba
yeah yeah yeah so you would be yeah yeah
yeah but you would be your brain in my
boss yeah there's actually a lot of
really interesting study where
consciousness has got intertwined in
some way like my gut neurons were
working with your brain neurons and yeah
but we're constantly evolving like what
a three in conscious person yeah but
what if then the consciousness is would
intertwine with like a certain
percentage so like a majority of your
percentage would be taken but you'd
still have some of my person I would
pose you with the question of what is
consciousness right everybody I'm no man
it has different definitions yeah and
nobody really knows one of my friends a
Leo majority was just on the show he
answered that question with life force
what does that mean force of life okay
that's what consciousness is the force
of life so even an animal has force of
life animals have and they're not even a
plan task force of life do you need a
brain to have consciousness
do you need some sort of like mmm like
I don't know I'm pretty I'm pretty sure
that a plant has no neurons right yeah
okay but then a plant still
photosynthesizes yeah so you like
phototropism they like respond to their
environment yeah yeah
are they consciously doing that what is
consciousness mm-hmm yeah yeah so so
maybe yeah but he said life force we've
heard other things on the show but this
is that is one of our questions as what
is consciousness I'm glad that you you
know I said you don't believe in the
mind you don't you don't believe in
mind-body dualism or you I do believe in
my body duals are separate damn you're
like super contrarian to like a lot of
the whole like mind body like spirit you
know that's all I I mean right now my
mind and body are very connected right
and this is who I am but there's like
there's actually a very interesting VR
experiment that's been done where like
you and I can be back to back and we're
wearing VR headsets and I'm seeing what
you would actually be seeing and you are
seeing what I'm seeing so it tricks our
brain yeah into like like if I look down
I'm seeing your arms and if you look
down you're seeing my arms and how does
that change your brain right I'm still
an immediate I think when I do that but
I'm learning what it's like to be Alan
in an arena right oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then the slowly the more you get
better at that maybe the more that you
can learn how to empathize with other
people around the world being in their
bodies and yeah yeah there's also like
Deena with the phantom yeah yeah so like
I mean there's so many things that can
be done and you can I I think the mind
is the most powerful thing and then
everything else is kind of like a
feature of it like it for thinking
intact turns right the mind is the
product and then everything else is a
feature but how close is the heart to
the mind in terms of the importance I
think that's a different question right
like I think the mind or sorry the heart
is connected to the brain and the brain
is connected to the mind and the mind is
what we perceive the brain and the heart
are working in different ways
hearts racing it's making a signal to
the brain and then the mind picks it up
is like oh I'm like maybe nervous in
this situation or did I drink too much
coffee today she's your intern -
interpretation but but it seems time the
heart beats and you know emanates that
that pulse pierces through through
energy through water through vibration
brain doesn't do that
brain has electricity mm-hmm but yeah I
don't know like do do yoga oh yeah okay
so like you're in service now in any
pose right your body can be in complete
stillness but your mind can be racing
that happens all the time right
always mind-body dualism okay okay fair
that's a yeah that's it that's why we're
talking yeah we like the black sheep
that are running in the direction that
the 19 that the 99 are running in the
different direction we totally love that
that's why we talk about this a side
question cuz it's usually the 99 sheep
are right yeah but in the times that the
black sheep is right it's always very
fascinating because they're the only one
that's thinking it and then we try and
think about that so I don't right or
wrong here it's just what I think yeah
that last example good vision I think
everyone's felt not even if you haven't
done yoga you felt when you're laying in
bed and your body's completely still but
your mind is going way too fast for you
to go to sleep so yeah okay and do you
think we're alone in the cosmos have any
like I have no concrete evidence yet I
think I just want to believe there's
other things out there yeah does it
inspire you to think that yeah yeah yeah
like it would be so cool in like 40
years where we're like we made contact
with another civilization and then
there's another way to for us to
communicate and like yeah exactly
I know that's not yeah me too
do you think there's another
these new there's another anumita and
Alan speaking in another parallel
universe right now I wouldn't say no
immediately yeah yeah I think it'd be
really cool yeah I I thought that during
our conversation I used to think so this
is like me being like a crazy child when
I used to play Barbies I had all these
like worlds created for Barbies and I
was just like how I like would imagine
things and for a portion of me like
childhood I was like four five I was
convinced that like there was like an an
imino or like a god-like figure that was
like determining her day to day is I'm
just playing with us like we were a toy
in someone else's world like I created
this world and I was controlling
everything perfect yeah and then that
same thing was going better
yeah that was just like I call a couple
days yeah that's good you had that one
you were how old
oh that's so good yeah that's exactly
what I'm gonna do I thought if you see
these Barbies that you're controlling
right now there's another thing that's
controlling you doing this right now
yeah yeah I'm just in a parallel
universe never ends do you think that
we're in base reality or computer
simulation based reality why are you so
sure cuz I watch The Truman Show and
that's what I made the decision after is
because I thought about the good time I
don't have reason it's just what I think
enemy to us such a pleasure yeah thanks
so much thank you thank you thank you
thank you
maybe we do a little different yeah
[Music]
this is nice thank you you're welcome
thank you it's such a pleasure let's
let's get more people using IBM's
developer tools around get a developer
about ibm.com/developerworks umthe
'uncle from the conversation and if you
did take something cool from the
conversation to share it with other
people and like comment subscribe we'd
love to hear from you hopefully we'll be
doing more conversations with the Watson
team and we'll strike up a cool
partnership moving forward and I know
that'll be very interesting for all you
guys you guys love AI and robotics and
the future and machine learning and chat
BOTS and VR and AR they love all this
stuff so to be able to work with IBM
would be such a pleasure on a longer
scale so and also join us on patreon we
need to pay for our studio our
electricity our food our team our all
this stuff so the equipment to make a
safe space for our guests so join us on
patreon we'd greatly appreciate it and
we'll catch you guys in about thirty
minutes or so with dr. Aubrey de Grey
speaking about health and aging and
fighting aging so thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you